.
J'en parle avec un chirurgien
orthopédiste dans quelques
reportage.
- Oui, ça va tr
Léo Bureau Blouin a subi
une chirurgie po
des ligaments au genou.
- Un petit ligament
sur le côté d'est pas
l'orthopédiste qui l'a opéré
qui fai, mais plutôt
la physiothérapeute Manon Pilon.
- Excellent!
- À.
MANON PILON, physothérapeute,
professeure adjointe, UdeM
- Je pense pas que ce soit
nécessaire de voédiste aujourd'.
Le croisé, il part d'ici et
il s'en vient sur votre fémur.
- Et parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autrreau Blouin n'aura pas
à revoir l'orthopédiste.
LÉO BUREAU BLOUIN, patient
- L'important, c'était surtout
d'avoide la santé qui connaît
le genou, qui connait
ma situation, qui peut un peu
me rassurer, répondre à mes
ce qui me rassure aussi,
c'est que je sais que le m
est pas loin si jamais
il y a des complications.
d'Orthopédie de l'Hôpital Jean-
Talon, les physiothérapeut
font la majorité des cas.
Dr JULIO FERNANDES, orthopédiste
75 sur 100 n'ont pas besoin
de voir un orthotant
donné qu'encore une fois,
on en a déjà parlé, c'est
peuvent être vus directement
par le professionnel.
est l'instigateur de cette
ue unique dans le secteur
hospitalier au Québec.
récie l'imrécie l'imrécie l'imre
des physiothérapeutes.- Bien, çe
que ça me libère pour
plus complexes. Ça me libère
une journée où, par exemple,
en salle d'opération.
- Bonjour, Dr Fernandes,
- Et il intervient pour les cas
plus complexes, i
d'Alain Lallio, qui a chuté
d'un deuxième étage.
on parlait, la luxation
claviculaire.
- Il pense que les
physiothérapeutes sont
en orthopédie.
- Imag 300 000
consultations par année.
Si on avait 180 physios au
année, bien, on verrrait 360 000
on pourrait
absorber toute la demande
de l'année avec 180
physiothérapeutes.
l'Irlande, qui compte cinq
ns d'habitants,
se sont aussi tournés
vers les physiothérapeutesf. agé
École de réadaptation, UdeM.- E5
physiothérapeutes en pratique
avancée en Irlans tempss tempsss
d'attente de 50 %.- Mais comme r
l'implication des infirmières,
le Québec est mutres provinces.
- En Ontario, les
physiothérapeutes peuvent
prescrire plus d'imagerie,
peuven
- Québec continue à analyser
la pertinence de déléguer
pour soulager les orthopédistes
qui sos.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.s.
- Ça fait plaisir, mon cher!
- Ici Davide Gentile,